MANDY WAITE: We're going to
be talking for about an hour
or so on how to design, build
a [INAUDIBLE] application.
We're going to use an
example application, one
that we wrote specifically
for a specific purpose.
I'm going to walk through
the kind of design decisions
that we made when it came
to build an application.
Why we made them, if there
are any other drawbacks,
any other pitfalls,
and just basically
drill down into the
application architecture.
And so how many of you
either went to Google I/O,
or went to Google I/O Extended?
OK, a few of you.
OK.
So those of you that
did see the talks.
And if you saw the cloud
stuff specifically,
the keynote and the
track that contained
the cloud specific
talks, you may
have seen this application
called, WalkShare.
So what we decided to
do for the whole event
was to have one application as
a theme for all of the talks.
Well, at least
half of the talks.
Some talks didn't
really go anywhere
near WalkShare, where
they could've done.
So a couple of months
before Google I/O,
we took the decision to
build this application
called WalkShare.
Anybody guess what it does?
Yeah?
So basically, it gathers data,
GPS track data from your phone
as you're walking along,
as you're doing a fun walk.
And at the end of the
walk, you can then
upload it to the internet and
share it with your friends.
Your friends can
then comment on it.
This is an Android application.
We don't have iOS support.
We were demonstrating
the features of Android
specifically.
But we also had a web
front end as well.
And this is the web front end.
This effectively allow people
to go and look at walks
and make comments on the walks.
So here's an example
here of a walk.
Sorry, can we
switch to the demo?
So this is an example walk.
One of the guys who
wrote this did this walk.
This is the Googleplex.
And basically what we're
doing, as the walk progresses,
we're recording GPS tracks, GPS
positions at certain places,
at certain points
within the walk,
then uploading
them to the cloud.
Then we have this
web user interface
that can actually
display the walk.
And what it's doing
is effectively
looking at the lat-long
of the GPS track,
and finding the appropriate
Street View image
to effectively show
you what the walk was
like using Street View.
So that's the Googleplex.
You can always make
comments, and so there's
some comments on here.
And I can add another comment.
Let's say Mandy.
And, hey, that was a long walk.
And just to
highlight something--
I meant to delete
this comment earlier.
But if I put a smiley
face in there--
there's a bug in our
code-- and hit Return,
I get double smilies.
And this is a Unicode
conversion problem.
There's a bug in the
code that we'd really
like to fix at some point.
So I've added comments.
Can we go back to
the slides, please?
So that was a demo.
So we basically have two
major user interfaces
for our application.
We have a web application
that allows us to view walks,
and we have the Android
application itself.
So obviously we need
some point, some place
where we can actually share
data between these two
instances of the user interface.
And for that, we need
to supply an API.
For a traditional
web application,
we don't actually need an API.
For a mobile device,
you really do.
But in this case, we're
using the same API
to read the same kind of data.
And in the best practices
of micro services.
And we'll talk more about
modular application design
later.
We chose to make a
modular application.
And the modules were Tracks.
This is effectively gathering
track data from the mobile app,
and also pushing that track data
out to the web user interface.
A Comment module
that allows to handle
all the aspects of
commenting, and a Leaderboard
module, because we
wanted to display the top
walks-- or not necessarily
a top walks in this case.
I'm not quite sure why
we designed it this way.
But we basically
have the top users,
the ones whose walks
had the most comments.
In order to make this work,
we need persistent storage.
We need persistent
storage or free modules
of the application.
And we also need temporary
storage, which we'll see later.
So we're going to go into
architecture in detail.
Quickly running
through the agenda,
this is what we're going to do.
Architectural decisions,
plan for getting big,
scaling, running the
app in production,
which we may not get to.
This talk generally runs
for about 75 minutes.
So we're going to
drop something.
So I'm going to try
and be a bit dynamic
in the way we present it.
And then finally,
I'm definitely going
to go through the
coming soon stuff.
So architecture decisions.
This is our shopping list for
our WalkShare application.
We wanted somewhere to store
the data from the mobile device.
So it had to be
persistent, and it
had to be accessible
from the mobile.
We also needed a modular,
autoscaling, frontend, and API.
We needed things to
be easy to develop.
After all, we work at Google.
We're really busy, and we don't
have a huge amount of time
to spend developing
applications at Google I/O.
And also, because it's likely
to break during the keynote,
it needs to be very easy to
maintain so we can go up there
on stage and fix it
and look really cool.
We also need robust
commenting system.
We'll talk about
that more shortly.
And we also need a database
for temp/summary data.
And again, the reasons why
we need another database
for storing temporary data,
we'll talk about later.
So the first question is,
where do we store our walks?
[INAUDIBLE] these GPS tracks.
So for this, on
our shopping list
is storage that's available
to us from a mobile device.
So we can upload
data from a mobile,
and access it through the
rest of the application.
So for this, we chose
Cloud Datastore.
And the Cloud
Datastore, we're going
to get into the
details of why and what
the Cloud Datastore
does shortly.
Why did we choose
the Cloud Datastore?
So this is the Cloud Datastore.
It's something that we
use internally, and is
exposed externally as a service.
We're going to get more into the
details and the history of that
in the next slide.
It's effectively an
NoSQL Store, a key value
store that can scale massively.
It has ACID transactions,
support for ACID transactions,
strong consistency on
reads and these things
called ancestor queries,
where we can group data,
or make queries along
that group of data,
and get extremely
good performance,
and also strong
consistency across-- which
is where our temporary
data problem comes along
across these entity groups,
these ancestor groups,
we have a bit more
of a problem, which
is why we need a
temporary database.
It's completely schemaless.
You don't need to think about
the underlying data structure,
although, our
abstraction libraries.
So we have the Java, which
includes JDO and JPA.
Might force you down
that route anyway.
And you can also
use Python as well,
and you can also create models
from those abstractions.
So you don't have to
have a data model,
but you can through
the abstractions.
And as mentioned, it
scales automatically.
You don't have to do anything.
There's nothing you need to
do in terms of provisioning
infrastructure, just
like with BigQuery.
It's completely
managed for you shard
and replication all
taken care of for you.
And there were some shortcuts
we might mention later
that might help you with that.
But generally, you don't
have to worry about scale
at all with Cloud Datastore.
So back in the day, we invented
this thing called, BigTable.
We published a
white paper on it.
And BigTable is this
massively scalable
NoSQL data store that
we use internally
for services such as Gmail.
And when we built App Engine to
service our needs for something
that would serve web
applications internally
within Google, we
decided to build
App Engine around BigTable--
added a layer on top of it.
Since then, another
layer has been
added in between those layers.
But we have BigTable,
Megastore, and then
we have the Datastore
on top of it.
So we're effectively
accessing this BigTable
through Datastore, and
that was tied to App Engine
for quite awhile,
for about five years.
But now it's available
everywhere as an API.
So we've opened it up
completely, no longer just
requires App Engine.
You can access it as an
API-- either a restful API,
or a protocol buffers API.
One of the great
things about it is
if you run a query on a data
set within the Datastore,
if it's 100 megabytes,
you're running the same query
across 100 megabytes
or 100 gigabytes.
It will take the same amount
of time to come back to you.
So the data set,
the size of data,
it doesn't matter when it
comes to running queries.
Data, of course, is replicated
across multiple data centers
in a region.
The stage is creaking.
And you can use it from any
application and language.
It's a restful API.
We have client library
support for most
of the major popular
programming engines.
At the time of writing, and it's
probably increased since then,
we were serving about 4 and
1/2 trillion requests per month
with the Cloud Datastore.
What about other situations
that might arise?
What about alternatives?
So if you have an application--
and this planes well-- decision
making process, we were never
going to build this with SQL.
But if you have an
application of your own
that already uses SQL, and you
want to pull it into the cloud,
and run it in the cloud, and
make use of managed Cloud SQL
resources, then you could
do this with Cloud SQL.
Cloud SQL is effectively
MySQL in the Cloud.
It offers you managed instances
of MySQL, up to 16 GB of RAM,
and 100 GB storage, and
fully managed for you.
All you have to do
is create a databases
and add and manage your
data in the form of tables.
Again, data is replicated
in many geographic locations
within a region,
and all the failover
handled automatically for you.
And we have a scheduling
mechanism for backups
as well, so we can
do backups for you
on your behalf-- schedule those
backups via user interface.
It also is very
easy to get access
to, easy to migrate data
from and to Cloud SQL.
It support things
like MySQL dump.
It supports the
MySQL wire protocol,
which means you can
use the MySQL client.
And it supports JDBC.
So it's just like MySQL,
except when in the Cloud,
[INAUDIBLE] is managed for you.
It has a flexible
challenging model.
So you can either
choose for pay per use,
pay as you go to
effectively with MySQL,
of you can choose
a package option.
It's available in EU, US,
and Asia data centers.
And if you're using
App Engine and you
want to use a Cloud SQL, you
will co-locate your MySQL
instances with the application--
either be in EU or US.
We don't have App Engine
support within Asia currently,
although you can run AccessApps
from App Engine in Asia.
Not in China though.
So what about files?
What about large blob data?
Images, videos, backups,
those kind of things?
So for that, we
have cloud storage.
And cloud storage is a bucket
based storage, an objects
store.
It allows you to
store pretty much
any amount of data-- up
to 5 terabytes per object.
It supports full object version.
So you can turn versioning on
and support multiple versions
of your objects, keep
a history of them.
It supports notifications.
So you effectively register
notifications on a bucket
and you basically say,
whenever something
changes within this
bucket to the data in it,
data's added or updated,
I want you to fire off
a request or a web hook, a URL
that we can then do something
with.
Might be an App
Engine application
that handles this URL for us.
In fact, if anybody
saw my Google I/O talk,
that's exactly what we
did for my demonstration.
It also, if you have 5 terabytes
for object potentially,
you really do need resumable
uploads and downloads.
It has a free 9s SLA through
things like high availability,
georedundancy, the
full replication system
that we've talked about already
with Datastore and cloud SQL.
It also features strong
read after write consistency
for objects.
So basically, if
you add an object
or change an object,
and that completes,
anybody who then
subsequently reads
that object will see
your changes, guaranteed.
They'd read that
object specifically,
always guaranteed.
And that's pretty powerful
for this kind of object store.
It's not the same for listings.
If you do a list
on the bucket, that
will be eventually consistent.
So you may see different results
if you were just listing.
But it's strongly consistent
for object updates.
And as with all of our services,
data is encrypted at rest,
and we give you all
of the tools you
need to provide
access to your data.
You can make data in cloud
storage publicly available.
You can even deploy
entire websites
on cloud storage
using static content.
And I need to drink some water.
I'll be drinking water
quite constantly.
Oh, gone past that.
So that solved
our first problem.
We've chosen the Datastore
to store data from mobile.
And how do we share walks?
So for this, we need this
modular frontend and API,
a comment missing.
There's a comment
missing from this.
Unfortunately,
forgot to update it.
A modular autoscaling
frontend and API.
And we also want it to be
easy to develop and maintain.
So we chose App Engine.
How many of you have
heard of App Engine?
Yeah, quite a few of you.
So App Engine, we love
App Engine at Google.
Why do we love App Engine?
Let's talk about App Engine.
So App Engine effectively
allows you, as a developer,
to focus on
developing your code,
developing your application,
and not have to worry about all
of your stuff like
this-- building software
stacks, provisioning machines,
installing databases,
installing software
stacks like LAMP stamps,
that kind of thing.
It supports managed
software stacks.
And these are fully managed
software stacks for Python,
for Java, for PHP, and
Go, with more on the way.
With App Engine, one thing we
always talk about is Autoscale.
App Engine's Autoscale
was legendary.
I'd like to call
it best of breed,
but probably the
marketing people
would jump on me if I said that.
But Autoscale is what App
Engine is really famous for.
It can scale out very rapidly,
and scale down very quickly
to make sure you always have
the resources you need when you
need them, but you only
pay for what you use.
It's also very easy
to develop, and that
was one of the things
on our shopping list.
We want it to be
easy to develop.
It's free to get started.
You don't have to enter
any credit card information
at the moment to use App Engine.
And you get some quota--
a reasonable amount
of quota per day, and
it cycles every day
that you can use to
run your applications.
So if you have a small
application you want to run,
you can run it on App
Engine free of charge.
You also have the ability
to build and test locally.
And we'll look at
that in more detail.
And again, it comes
back to the whole point,
you see, you can focus on
developing your application
code, and not worry about
building software stacks.
Trivial to manage, that
was another item one
on our shopping list.
It's fully managed, all of these
instances that run your code,
or all these software stacks.
We applied appaches, we
apply all of the updates.
And they're maintained
24/7 by the guys
that Julia mentioned earlier,
these SRAs, Site Reliability
Engineers.
So yet we don't need
to worry about that.
And you can handle these things
is in demand for Autoscale.
So the different
traffic patterns
that we see on a regular basis,
things like spikes in traffic,
which is the bottom
one here, computes
the linear scalability,
the exponential scale,
logarithmic scale.
It can handle all
those kind of changes.
And most importantly, even
if you have an application
that has periods of inactivity.
These could be on a
daily basis, maybe
at night in the
location where you're
running the application on a
weekly basis, a monthly basis,
on a yearly basis, maybe
in summer holidays,
then you won't be
consuming any resources.
So you won't be
paying for anything,
which is really important, and
a huge difference from when
it comes to buying
in premise servers
and putting them
next to your machine,
next to your desk
in your garage,
or buying space in a co-lo,
or something like that.
So App Engine is
extremely flexible
when it comes to handling
changes in demand.
Local development environment
is also really important.
This is the ability to really
build and test your application
before you ultimately
deploy it to production.
And we use the
Cloud SDK for this.
Example code, there's
gcloud app run.
You run this on your
laptop or on your desktop.
It will run the
application locally.
It effectively runs
App Engine locally,
including the Cloud Datastore,
which we looked at earlier.
So it has its own data store.
When you shut the environment
down, start it again,
it had the same data
stored in the Datastore.
So you can test, iteratively,
your entire application.
And once you're done,
you can deploy it
to production using
the same command.
In this case, it would
just be gcloud app deploy,
with a dot, which is
the current directory.
And there's some example
output as well from the console
showing us the Dev
app server, which
is what we call it internally.
It's not running.
App Engine architecture,
I'm not going
to spend too much time on this.
But it's important to realize
we have a pending queue.
And we have instances
that are spun up
to handle requests coming
into that pending queue.
And we have a scheduler that
will monitor the pending
requests and spin up
new instances on demand,
or remove instances
when there is no demand.
And we have other services
like Task Queue, which we'll
look at shortly, and the
Datastore, which I mentioned,
and memcache, which we'll
also look at shortly.
We have another
interactive version
with this diagram
coming up soon as well.
So we did talk
about this earlier,
the touch on the idea of modular
development for applications.
And this is also really,
really important as well.
This allows us to
effectively take
a large application, a large
monolithic application,
and allow us to factor it out
into small logical components
called modules.
And modules are a top
level of App Engine.
They can be in any language.
WalkShare, for
example, was developed
in Python, Go, and Java.
You add free modules, the
free modules you saw earlier,
and they were written in
three different languages.
So if you have guys who are
specialists in Go developing
backend code, they can be
developing the Go application
as a module.
And other people can be
doing the front end stuff
in Java or Python.
And all of that stuff can be
merged into one application.
Modules have versions.
So we can deploy
versions of the module.
Different versions-- versions
1, version 3, the test version.
And we can switch between those
modules, as we'll see shortly.
Modules also can be
backed by Compute Engine
virtual machines.
And I think Julia spent a
lot of time on Compute Engine
earlier, so you
know what they are.
We'll talk about
them more shortly.
But basically, the module
will be an App Engine module.
But instead of being backed by
these traditional App Engine
instances, they will be
backed by Compute Engine
virtual machines.
Modules can share state
across the entire application.
So each module has
access to state
stored in Memcache
and Datastore.
They have their own performance
settings, their own versions.
They can be deployed and updated
independently of each other.
So we need an API.
And that's the whole
point of this one.
In order to share
walks, we need an API.
Without the API, the application
would be stuck on the phone.
We couldn't actually
share that data
with the other front end,
the web user interface.
So we need to build an API.
So in this case, we chose to
build an API from scratch.
And it looks
something like this.
So this is a standard kind
of restful example of an API.
This is one call, obviously.
This is so comments--
and effectively,
for this user, called userbob,
we want to see walk 1.
And basically, our API will
suck in JSON, and return JSON.
Everybody know what JSON is?
I guess you probably do.
So here's an example of the
output from that request we
call gets on that URL,
which is a restful URL
And it returns back a JSON
object representing that data.
And I think we can
show a demo now.
Can we switch back
to the laptop?
OK.
Just want to refresh this.
I'm in Chrome.
I'm in the Chrome
developer's console,
and what I'm interested
in is looking for calls
to the comment API.
I was going to refresh that and
let it load the whole thing.
But because we're
using the filter,
we can see-- our call to
comment/userbob/walk1.
That's what it looked like.
And response was JSON back.
So again, we could be
actually updating a comment
or adding a walk.
And in that case, it would be
post request with a post body.
We could be updating
a walk using
put requests, those
kind of things.
So it's a very simple API.
We can also do tricky
things like this as well.
I'll get rid of this.
Oh, help.
What happened then?
Yeah, I don't want to report
inappropriate street view.
This is the Googleplex,
nothing inappropriate about it.
So we have an
interface that allows
us to show you the output
from the restful cause.
So this case, we made a call
to comment userbob, walk1,
which we saw an example.
And we can also look at
the actual route as well.
And as the GPS coordinates
for all steps in that walk.
So these are the GPS
traces that were sent back.
So this is just a useful way
of querying the API for us.
OK.
So you can go back
to the slides?
So building your own API.
And I'll talk about why we
built our own API shortly.
But you don't have to
build your own API.
I think Jerome already
mentioned it, Cloud Endpoints.
We have this thing called
Google Cloud Endpoints.
Allows you to simplify the whole
process of building an API,
and exposing it to clients,
clients such as mobile devices,
to gaming applications,
to web applications.
And basically, the
whole idea is-- well,
there's two approaches
to doing this.
That's kind of free, but the two
we're going to talk about are.
You can take your existing
client interface application
code which may be part
of a web application
that you have already.
And you can decorate
it, add decorators to it
in the form of annotations.
And we have an
example coming up.
And that will effectively
instruct App Engine
and the underlying cloud
endpoint's run time.
Do you want to
expose this method?
And again, I'll
look at the example
shortly, as an API call?
It's very, very simple.
Alternatively, you can
take a model class,
like a comment or a walk.
You've already defined a model.
And it doesn't
have an API for it.
But using tooling--
it's available in things
like Android Studio, or Eclipse.
You can basically generate an
endpoint class from that model.
So all you have to do
is right click on it,
say generate endpoint
class, and it
will generate the class for you.
And this will allow
you to perform
all of the standard type
restful calls on that resource.
So I think of it as a resource.
[INAUDIBLE] a comment or a walk.
You can do lists,
you can do gets.
You can do puts.
All of the kind of things you
would do with a restful API.
And this is all generated
automatically for you.
You don't have to
write any code at all.
The APIs that App Engine
creates are effectively
implemented on top of the
exact same infrastructure
that we use for our own APIs.
So for maps, and for YouTube.
Completely discoverable.
And obviously, you get
all of the kind of scale
that we have for our own APIs.
We also provide tours
that are required
for generating effectively
mobile optimized client
libraries.
So effectively, we
have an API here.
We want to be able
to consume that
from an application running on
a device, or running a web app.
What we need is
a client library,
something that understands
how to envoke that API.
And we can generate that
straight from the application
code, straight from the end
points that we generated.
And we have tools for
Android, iOS, and web,
and these are
available in things
like Android studio
and Eclipse, also
for Objective-C on a command
line, and also for JavaScript
as well.
Because this is going through
Google and the Google front
end, we have full out of the box
denial of service protection.
It supports OAuth2 as
well, authentication,
and also supports
client key management.
As an example, I kind of
hacked this together earlier,
because my example
wasn't WalkShare.
So this is basically
a WalkShare method,
say, get comments that would
return a list of comments.
And what we've done
is we've annotated it.
We've annotated the
class initially.
We're at API.
Name equals comment
is effectively saying,
we want this API to
be called comment.
We want the version to be v1.
And then we've
annotated the method,
a bit of indentation
problems there.
And we've said, we want
this to be a get request.
That could be inferred by
the system from the fact
that this is a get request.
So we don't have to
actually put this there.
But we did anyway just to
show it and highlight it.
And also, the path
for this method,
what it will be when we
make a REST call to it.
Then we can also annotate the
parameters of the method call.
In this case, walk
ID and user ID.
And then the body of the
code, effective just some
kind of query on
a comment system,
and returns back
matching results.
And in the comments there at
the bottom of the first box
is what the REST call like,
slash comment slash v1 userid,
walkid.
And then after we've generated
a client library for this,
we could then consume
that from Android.
Basically we have to get
a version of the endpoint.
And here, we say
service.comment endpoint.
This is available from
the client library call
get comments, passing the userid
and the walkid, which we've
gathered from the user
interface, and call execute.
And that will get the
results back for us.
So why didn't we just
start with endpoints?
Well, we talked about
managed virtual machines
a couple of times
already in the keynote,
and also in Julia's talk.
And when we started
developing this application,
we wanted to use managed VMs.
But they didn't have
all of the plumbing
because it was still
early in their life cycle.
And they're not
fully released yet,
they're still in
limited preview.
They didn't have all
of the plumbing that
was required to actually
support Cloud Endpoints.
So we couldn't use them.
So we had to actually build
the API from scratch by hand.
Sorry, it's been a long day.
What about other situations?
So we didn't use Memcache
for this application,
but we could do.
A Memcache is extremely
important for most people.
It saves having to do
those expensive wreaths
from the backing store,
be it the Cloud Datastore,
or be it Cloud SQL.
You don't want to go back
and get the same data
all of the time once
you've already have it.
So you store it in Memcache.
And here we have an example
of three applications,
all accessing a shared Memcache.
This is a Memcache that's shared
across all applications run
in the region.
So we have a shared Memcache
for applications one in the US,
the shared memache for
applications running in the EU,
in Europe.
And it's a large shared
cache, and we make it bigger,
the more applications we have.
But it's still the possibility
that your data maybe
be evicted by
somebody else's data.
So there's no predictability or
deterministic nature about it.
We also have an option called
dedicated Memcache, which
allows you to reserve
specific size of Memcache
for your application
specifically.
So it's reserved
by per gigabyte,
and you pay per gigabyte.
So this would
effectively allow you
to control the way data
is evicted from Memcache.
Task Queues-- how many people
have heard of App Engine Task
Queues?
Because most people loved them.
So somebody here?
Yep?
So these are really popular.
Now, people love Task Queues.
Whenever anybody gets involved
in App Engine development,
they love using Task Queues.
What it effectively
does is allow
us to make incoming
requests from users.
And then because
we had to respond
to the user at a
reasonably quick time,
we don't wait 60 seconds.
There was a deadline
on respondencies
as of 60 seconds in App Engine.
We don't want to wait
that length of time.
We may need to do stuff
in the background.
So what we can do is while
we're processing the request,
we'll generate a task
to say, do this stuff.
Put it onto a Task Queue.
And then we can go back to
the user and say, we're done.
So this could be generating
email, processing a tax return
form, or something like that.
Something complicated.
And the Task Queue, effectively,
has tasks which are web hooks.
And they're handle by
other App Engine instances,
instances specifically written
to handle those requests.
And these can run for
longer than 60 seconds.
They can run
continuously, or they
can run for a longer
period of time,
but not necessarily 60 seconds.
And what they can do is process
all of these jobs outside
of the user request
in the background.
They can access all of the
services, other instances
an App Engine can run,
things like Cloud Datastore,
Google Cloud Storage, email.
We have a mail API, and other
external APIs, APIs external
to Google.
So this is a really
effective way
of actually managing background
processing on App Engine.
But it also allows
us surplus workout
to things like Compute
Engine or to anything else.
We can have Compute Engine
reading tasks from these cues,
and slightly
different type of cue,
and process that data offline,
outside the user request,
but also outside of App Engine.
You could also build
the whole thing yourself
on Compute Engine.
But why would you
want to do that?
We'll talk about Compute
Engine more shortly.
So that's covered the
next two bullet points.
Let's go onto the next
one, which is comment SPAM.
So I've never really
built a web form recently,
but I know what the
horror stories are.
As soon as you create
a formal on the web
and you put it
onto your website,
there are spam bots out
there that will say, ha!
A form!
And they would go in it,
and they would fill it
in to their heart's content.
And you will have spam, lots and
lots of spam in your comments.
So generally, people
protect their comments,
their commenting system either
via requiring to use a login
or using captures.
So we need a robust
commenting system.
So we use captures.
Who likes captures?
You like captures?
Right, nobody likes captures.
But they are effective,
particularly when
your user has not logged in.
But captures actually require
you do some image processing.
And as Julia has
already mentioned,
image processing on App Engine
is a little bit difficult.
We don't have the libraries
in place [INAUDIBLE]
to make it work.
And for our Java component of
our application, a Java module,
we didn't have the java.awt
library-- java.awt!
My colleague added this
slide, and I hadn't even
really given thought to
java.awt for a long, long time.
[INAUDIBLE] back in my past.
But you can use java.awt to
process images, image data.
So App Engine doesn't
have this library.
It's been removed.
It's a big overhead,
it's a big chunk of stuff
that we don't need.
So what are we going to do?
We'll use managed VMs.
So we talked about managed
VMs already quite extensively.
Laptops gone off.
And I'm not going to
go into anymore detail.
But basically, we
can use managed
VMs to effectively break
the glass, as Julia said.
We can break the glass and say,
this won't run on App Engine.
We can run this on
Compute Engine, that's
fine-- modular application
design, no problem at all.
We can just have to
managed virtual machines
running that aspect
of our application.
And the capture system
looks something like that.
Let me show you what it
looks like in real life.
Can you go to the
laptop, please?
OK.
So going back, I actually have
a better walk we can work with.
I kind of recognize that place.
I love Times
Square, I really do.
I don't know why I love
Times Square, but I do.
And we're going to tragically
run out of time, aren't we?
So in a moment,
with comments, we
don't have any captures, right?
We've already looked at this.
So we click on this.
I can just type
in-- so anybody can
come along and make comments.
They can put URLs in
there to send me to places
where I really don't want to go.
So I want to stop this.
So how do I do it?
So fortunately, and also
covering this issue here
with the two smiley
faces, the tech-op guys
have just called me on
my secret earpiece here
to tell me that
they've just deployed
version 2 of the application.
And we can actually just
switch over to that version,
and it will fix
our problem source,
add captures, and also
fix that problem there.
So what I need to do is find my
WalkShare stating application,
go to Versions.
And after a little while,
nobody demos on Wi-Fi.
Really-- seriously,
never do demos on Wi-Fi.
So at the moment, we can
see for our default module--
and again, we have a
notion of a default module.
We could've given
this a name, but we're
using this as the default.
This is the one that
handles our comment stuff.
And at the moment, the
version for that is version 1.
I can also look at
the comments one,
and that is also
going to be version
1-- think that's about it.
It's the Wi-Fi.
[INAUDIBLE] where are you?
If you see somewhere.
So we could see version
1 there as well.
And the tech-ops guys have
said version 2 has actually
got support for captures,
and it fixes our problem.
So I'm going to make
version 2 of the comments
module the default.
I was thinking about
it, that's done.
I'm also going to do
that for the default one
to fix the other problem.
Change that.
Make default.
And the user interface
has a problem here,
because I even saw my colleague,
Brian, do this as well.
Your first instinct is to
go to the Delete button,
and I don't know why.
But there's something about
the user interface and the way
it's designed that attracts
you immediately to delete,
and so we need to fix that.
So now, we can go back
to our application.
We want to refresh
that, because we
want to see the new
version of the application.
So let's go onto comments now.
We'll add a comment.
Ah, OK.
So my name is Mandy, and
this is a test comment.
Aw, can't you think
of anything better
to say than test comment?
And Android.
Then I can post my comment.
And if I don't
answer it correctly,
I do foobar, more foo.
It won't let me post.
OK, so now we've protected it.
We can also check as well to
see if we've fixed our issue.
And post a comment.
Oh, I didn't do--
very interactive.
I really can't type.
Obviously, the implementation
would have a different capture
every time, [INAUDIBLE]
might be quite easy to learn.
So now you see it.
We've fixed it.
We now have captures,
and we've also
fixed the bug with
the smiley face.
And in the actual
WalkShare demos
that we did during
Google I/I, we actually
showed them going live into
the code, and fixing that bug,
and updating it while they're
in production, which is great.
That was really clever.
That's not really available
yet, but it will be soon.
So can you go back to
the slides, please?
All right.
So we're getting there.
We have a robust
commenting system.
Now what we need is a database
for our comments leaderboard,
a database, effectively, for
temporary and summary data.
Now, we've already talked about
this problem that we have.
We have data that's
like [INAUDIBLE].
It's stored in tables, it's
stored as rows in databases.
When we want to do things
across an entire data set,
would count as specifically,
becomes a bigger problem,
a much more difficult problem.
And the Datastore's
not ideally suited
for doing those operations.
It is possible to do them.
We do have things like
sharded counters and suchlike.
But we wanted to do
something more interesting
and really stood out.
How many of you
have heard of Redis?
OK, a few of you.
Good.
And we're going to run
Redis on Compute Engine.
So we can't run
Redis on App Engine.
So we can easily run
it on Compute Engine
and just have the two
talk to each other.
So effectively, our
leaderboard will show us
which users are getting the
most comments on their walks.
[INAUDIBLE] time, I'll show you
what leaderboard looks like.
So why did we use Redis?
So using the right
tool for the job.
Redis, for those
of you who know it,
and for those of you
who don't know it,
is effectively an
in-memory key value store.
It's extremely powerful,
extremely fast.
One of the great features
that make it stand out
is the fact that values--
keys can be big things.
They can be images,
long strings.
But values can be objects.
They can be structured data.
They can be sorted sets.
And having a sorted set for
a value for a leaderboard
is perfect, exactly
what we need.
We can make updates to that
object whenever we need to,
and we can store and
extract it whenever
we want to back from Redis.
So Redis is perfectly suited
for this particular job.
So why Compute Engine?
Let's quickly go
through Compute Engine.
I think we've covered
it quite a bit today.
So Compute Engine effectively
gives us compute resources,
virtual machines, networking,
persistent discs--
all of the other things you
need to wire them together,
creating virtual private
networks, that kind of thing.
It's supported in US,
Europe, and Asia zones.
It adds this amazingly
fast software
defined networking based
backbone that it runs on,
which is exactly
the same network
that we use for our own stuff.
It features sub-hour billing.
Permanent billing, I think
Jerome covered that earlier.
There's no iOPS charges
for block storage.
So with some
providers, you actually
have to pay by the iOPS,
as well as the size.
For us, we only charge
you by the amount,
the size of your position disk,
and the size of your blocked
storage.
And we don't need to
provide virtual machines
for load balancing.
So again, in some
cases, you have
to provide a virtual machine.
With HAProxy, all this
can be automated for you.
But you have to spin
up a virtual machine
to do load balancing.
And if you want to
go big, you have
to have lots of virtual machines
to do the load balancing
for you.
That requires a
warm-up period, so it
could be quite expensive
to warm those up.
For us, we don't
have to do that.
We have effectively
what's called
cloud native load balancing.
Load balancing is inherent
in our infrastructure.
And so it's very easy
for us to load balance
across a huge
number of instances.
And I have an example
of that coming up.
Consistently fast, very
quick VM provisioning--
less than 20 seconds
or around 20 seconds
for a single instance.
Probably about less than two
minutes for 1000 instances.
Consistent
performance-- now this
is extremely important
to us with our services,
things like YouTube.
Really when you're
watching a YouTube video,
you don't want the fact that
somebody else is watching
a YouTube video to
affect your experience.
So it's extremely
important for us
to actually prevent
one person's activity
from impacting another.
And we get that
with cloud platform.
Also, cloud native
load balancing--
want to mention that.
This is the architecture of
a Compute Engine project.
I'm not going to go into this.
We support Debian,
CentOS, virtual machines,
but also for paid options,
we have SUSE, Red Hat Linux,
and in limited preview
we have Windows.
You can also run things like
Core OS, SE Linux, anything
you want to you can
run, but you may
have to build your own image.
Shared cores-- up to 16
shared core instances,
instances that share cores.
You'll have multiple of
these instances sharing
a core very cheap,
very, very cheap.
Perfect for experimenting or
just a weekend of hacking.
Anything up to 16 cores for
our biggest virtual machines.
After 60 gigabytes of RAM, I
know this is what we offer.
We have free memory
configurations-- high CPU,
standard, and high memory.
Standard has a certain
amount of memory for CPU.
High memory has more.
I can't remember what the
exact numbers are currently.
And high CPU has less.
So high CPU is perfectly
suited for compute intensive
workloads, and high
memory is perfectly
suited for
memory-hungry workloads.
Persistent Disk--
again I'll have
to sacrifice some
things to be expedient.
We only have about
15 minutes left.
But Persistent Disk, we
have standard disk or SSD.
You can effectively
attach this on demand,
if it's a data partition,
to your virtual machine.
So you can attach it
to one virtual machine,
disconnect it, and attach it
to another in read-write mode.
Or you can even attach it
to multiple virtual machines
in read-only mode.
Consistent I/O
performance, and I'm
going to skip forward there.
You can see the bullet points.
If you have any questions about
it, come and see me afterwards.
Local SSD is
something that's new.
It has some commonalities with
our standard position disk
offering-- per gigabyte pricing,
no I/O charges, performance
is consistent, office
encryption [INAUDIBLE].
Everything is encrypted at
rest, and live migration,
which we'll talk about shortly.
Kind of jumping the gun on that.
The difference is in
terms of reliability,
local SSD has nothing to offer.
The storage
redundancy, checksums,
and snapshots that persistent
disk offer are not available.
You have to do
all that yourself.
But what you get instead
is sub-millisecond latency.
So local SSD is like having
disks attached to your machine.
And it's very, very, very fast.
And in terms of flexibility,
up to 10 terabytes
of persistent disk, or one up
to four 375-gigabyte partitions
attached to any virtual
machine for local SSD.
And again, if you
want to know more,
come and see me afterwards.
Networking-- standard networking
stuff, TCP, UDP, static
and ephemeral IP addresses
for public interfaces.
Ephemeral IP addresses for
internal virtual machines,
but we have this thing called
automatic DNS, internal DNS,
which effectively allows you
to address virtual machines
by their name, and other things
like firewalls and such like.
I'm going to skip ahead, and I
apologize for skipping ahead.
But I want to go ahead and
get as much as possible done.
Live migration--
in the old days,
when I first joined
the cloud team,
we had to explain to people why
every now and again we would
take a zone down, a complete
zone like us-central1-a.
And you would have to
move all of your stuff.
We would have to take all
your virtual machines,
all your persistent
disks, and move it
from one zone to another
while we took this zone down.
What we would do when the
zone was down, we would update
the firmware, update the
software, we would get a broom,
and we would go and sweep out
the mouse crap from the racks.
All that stuff, and we would
have a lovely shiny zone
at the end of it, and then
you could but all your stuff
back again if you wanted to.
These days we have
live migration,
so we don't do an entire zone.
We do part of a zone at a time.
So what we do, we schedule
a maintenance event
on part of a zone.
Anything that's in
that part of a zone--
virtual machines or
persistent disks-- we move.
We move it to a different
part of the zone.
It's protected from
the [INAUDIBLE] then.
And we effectively
do a memory copy.
We do copies of all of data,
and you don't lose anything.
Effectively, for most people,
what you're going to see
is an entry in a log file
saying, we moved your stuff.
For latency-sensitive
applications,
maybe like mediastreaming,
it may be possible
that this brief interruption,
very, very brief interruption--
two milliseconds,
sub-millisecond even--
may be important to you, and
we do offer you the ability
to take your instances
down and move them.
GCE and Docker
have been covered.
But again, we can
talk about that
more later if you want to
during the drink stuff, which
I'm looking forward to.
Should be fun.
GCE is a great
place to run Redis.
So we've already established
we want to run Redis.
We've already established we
want to run our Compute Engine.
So our leaderboard
application is
going to make use of
temporary storage.
And that kind of looks
something like that.
When we have Compute Engine
with all register deployment,
ultimately you'll have an
option in Compute Engine
in the developer's console to
deploy everybody's clusters.
Just click to deploy.
At the moment, you have to do
that configuration yourself,
but you can use scripts
and other things as well.
Other things aren't
completely available yet
or available in limited
preview that I really
shouldn't talk about.
But we could talk
about that later.
But it is quite easy to
provision a Redis cluster
currently on Google
Compute Engine.
It's just that those
tools that we have
are not completely
available yet.
They're in limited preview,
and we're not really
supposed to talk about
limited preview stuff.
So that's what a Redis
cluster looks like.
Sorry.
I knew this was
going to be hard.
And we have millions.
We should always have millions.
And naturally I always have
my own millions as well.
So we've solved that
problem with Redis.
We have a database for
our template summary data.
That's cool.
And we're done, really.
That's the
architectural decisions.
These are the kind of
crises we went through when
designing and building
this application.
We didn't cover Android
or anything like that,
and we didn't
cover the libraries
we use for the user
interface, which
were, if you noticed based
on material design, what we
announced at Google
I/O is in Polymer.
What about planning
for getting big?
This is something I
know quite a bit about.
So back in November, I
worked on this project.
In fact, I led this
project to build
an application
for One Direction.
How many of you have
heard of One Direction?
So I get this all the time.
You've all heard
of One Direction.
You just won't admit it.
Right?
But they're a huge band.
They're a boy band.
They're huge.
They have 17 million Twitter
followers when I last checked.
They are one of the biggest
social media entities
on the planet.
And on the 23rd
of November, they
did a seven-hour live
stream on YouTube.
And they wanted, or
Sony Psycho Music
wanted to have a second
screen application that
would allow people watching
live stream to interact
with the whole thing.
They were basically asking
questions, six questions
every hour, 42
questions in total.
And they would get
rewards, badges,
and such like for
getting questions right.
And they could share
it with their friends
and say, hey, look.
I got this badge.
You didn't get it.
Ha ha ha.
But we estimated that probably
about 620,000 concurrent users
would access this application,
which is quite a large number.
This is what it
kind of looked like.
We saw-- again I don't want
to go into the details--
again, if you look
at my I/O talk
on making your cloud
services Google fast,
we go into more detail on this.
But basically we saw this
traffic pattern-- spikes
of up to 750 queries per second.
They're effectively
requests per second.
Think of them as
requests per second,
and that just carried
on for the seven hours.
Apart from when this happened,
when somebody actually
made an announcement on the live
stream about the application,
suddenly we were a
little bit nervous
about the application maybe
not being able to cope,
so we didn't really
talk about it too much.
But at some point
in live stream,
probably about four hours
in, they mentioned it,
and we saw this
huge uptake in users
accessing the application.
We would have a peak later on.
You have to handle
that kind of scale.
You never know when you're
going to be tech-crunched.
going to make it on to slashdot.
And everybody's going to come
and access your application.
If I was building
Walkshare, I would
expect Walkshare to
be extremely popular.
I would expect it to be the
most downloaded application
on the Android Play Store.
You've got to be
prepared for scale.
So let's talk about
scaling modules.
We looked at modules
earlier with App Engine.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
MANDY WAITE: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Is that
one of their songs?
MANDY WAITE: I'm sorry.
AUDIENCE: Be Prepared
to Scale-- is that?
MANDY WAITE: It's hard
to see who's talking.
Sorry.
But yeah.
So scaling for success
or something like that.
So modules, we looked
at modules earlier.
They have free options
when it comes to scaling.
The classic auto-scaling
option, which is basically
based on a very,
very complicated
algorithm that we have.
And basic scaling or manual
scaling, so basic scaling
basically says, this
is the maximum number
of instances while just using a
very, very crude way of scaling
within that boundary.
The manual scaling
effectively allows
you to add instances yourself.
Sorry.
Requires that you add
instances yourself.
So you're going to add
an instance manually
to make it scale.
Well, that's not
particularly responsive.
And App Engine Autoscale
looks something like this.
So I like this.
We have lots of requests.
They go into a
pending request queue.
We have an instance that's been
created to service requests.
This forwards busy, has
probably got 10,000 parts in it,
not just free.
So we spin up a new
instance very, very rapidly
to handle the requests,
and we move the requests
from the pending queue
onto the new instance.
Then we create a new instance
to handle the other requests.
This goes on ad infinitum.
As long as we have requests in
the pending queue, App Engine,
the scheduler itself
will be making decisions
about what to do.
Should I leave it in the
pending request queue
and wait for an instance
to become available,
or is it quicker for me
to spin up a new instance?
They have to make those
decisions in real time very,
very quickly.
But we all know that making
decisions pragmatically
is extremely quick, much quicker
than spinning up an instance.
So it can do that.
And it does it constantly.
That's basically saying,
do I need a new instance,
or can I just stay
in the pending queue?
You have a little bit of
control about how this works.
You can say, my
pending request latency
can be 900 milliseconds, say.
So don't do anything until
it's been in the queue for that
long.
If it goes over 900
milliseconds, take some action.
Maybe spin up a new instance.
And we also have these things
called idle instances as well,
so if an instance is not
available to service a request,
those requests will
be serviced-- sorry--
routed to the idle instance
which will service them,
while in the background spinning
up a new dynamic instance.
It's all very clever, and
it all works extremely well.
For modules such as
manual scale modules,
we have the option as I think
Julia showed you earlier
to control scalability
pragmatically by saying
modules.set_num_instances.
We want 42 of them.
And that's very easy to do.
Replica Pools-- Julia
mentioned Replica Pools before.
This is where we can create--
I love this term-- homogeneous
fleets of virtual machines.
All identical.
No snowflakes are all
absolutely identical.
Based on the template, and the
templates is on the left hand.
We basically define
the template,
feed into this mechanism
called Replica Pool,
and it will then go
and create this thing
called a resource view, which
contains a load balancer
and all of our virtual machines.
So if you want 10
virtual machines,
you will create 10
and then we have a
load balance endpoint
we can send all
of our traffic to.
So we can create
pools into size.
In a moment we can't
auto-scale them,
but we'll talk
about that shortly.
Also monitors the health
of these instances,
so if the instance goes away,
we can speed back up again.
Load balancing--
load balancing scale.
We talked about load
balancer earlier.
So we did some tests
back in November again,
I think, probably
about time of 1D Day
where we load balanced one
million requests per second
across a pool of
virtual machines,
and it really didn't take
any kind of ramp up time.
I think it took four seconds to
get ramped up and 120 seconds
to stabilize.
But very, very quickly, we
were able to load balance
one million requests across
a pool of virtual machines.
And it cost about
$10 to do that test.
Now the requests that
were being serviced
weren't particularly
complicated,
but it shows you
can scale massively.
This is a lot more than
the 10,000 requests
we saw with the
One Direction app.
When it comes to Redis,
the Redis solution we had
was based on Replica Pools.
So we have a load balancer--
oh, I missed a couple of errors
there.
I missed one error.
Basically our
leaderboard application
will talk to read-only
minions of Redis.
All updates, all write-up
dates are sent to the master,
and they're pushed out
to the millions which
service our requests
from the leaderboard app.
So do I have time for this?
Nobody's telling
me, so I'm going
to go ahead and do it anyway.
So when our application's
working, let me refresh that.
What I'm going to do is
go to Compute Engine.
So because we know
that one of our modules
has a load balancer
and a Replica Pool,
we can go and look at the
load balancer configuration.
We have a forwarding
rule, one IP address,
so all of the requests will
go to this one IP address,
and they will be routed
to a load balance pool
virtual machines,
which are these ones.
OK.
So we have six virtual machines
currently, and now six minions,
six Redis minions.
We should have a
picture of minions
here in the cloud [INAUDIBLE].
So I'm going to have a look
at this one particularly.
So that's been quite busy,
been doing some work.
I'm going to SSH into it.
And we have browser-based SSH.
It allows us to effectively
click a button and lot
into the virtual machine.
It transfers the SSH
keys and ultimately makes
the connection.
And again, it's dependent
on the Wi-Fi access
and also onto the mood
of the demo gods, which
we know are not very
happy at the moment.
And I can do PS
minus EF on here.
Ooh, end up bigger.
Maybe make the window smaller.
Yay.
Oh, wait.
So here-- I'm probably going to
need to scale out here a bit.
We can see these same
process on our Redis
stuff, the stuff we care about.
I want to come back out,
because I can't see it.
We have 12339, 13234.
And we're going to want to
kill the child process, which
is going to be 13229.
So I'm-- interesting.
So I'll kill those
processes off now.
Come on.
Like I said, the demon
processes don't win,
but it should be dead as far
as Compute Engine is concerned.
Back to our load balance pool.
And then we see it.
It's gone.
But it's not actually gone.
It's been marked as unhealthy
by the load balancer.
And we have a
health check set up
that will actually
detect the-- really?
Seriously?
Going to stop?
We have to get
this timing right.
This is such a great talk.
I could carry on talking
for another 20 minutes,
and you miss so
much great stuff.
But we'll get this
right next time.
And basically yes, we had this
health check that effectively
is a little go application
that has responded on port 8082
to slash check, and if that
doesn't respond on that port,
then it will effectively
mark that instance as bad
and no longer send
traffic to it.
So one of the other
instances in the target pool
will continue to receive
traffic as before,
but that one won't until
we bring it back up again.
Once it comes back up again, it
will be added back to the pool
and continue to
service requests.
And basically just, a wrap
up because Tom's telling me
I have to.
Go back to the slides please.
So basically that's it.
So we've gone through all
of the design decisions.
These last ones,
these last sections
I'm just going to drop anyway
for expediency effectively.
Because we just don't have
enough time to deliver it all.
The last couple of things
I wanted to mention,
and regard to Tom, you'll
have to come up and physically
throw me off the stage.
Coming soon, beyond
those virtual machines,
we have Docker support for
managed virtual machines.
Effectively managed
virtual machines,
instead of being just managed
virtual machines will also
run Docker.
And it'll look
something like this.
You'll provide a Docker file.
You'll provide your
configuration file,
and we will effectively register
your Docker image in a Docker
registry, and create a container
on a virtual machine for you,
and that will be what managed
virtual machines is based on.
Replica pools will
auto-scale eventually.
We already have that
limited preview.
If you're interested
in that, let me know.
We're looking for interest
in use cases for auto-scale,
because the guys are really
looking at how they can best
develop this kind of
technology, because
auto-scaling virtual
machines is interesting.
[INAUDIBLE] the
containers, maybe we
should be focusing more
on scaling containers
and not virtual machines.
And finally, saving mobile data.
We have this thing called Google
Cloud Save for Android, which
will simply by the
process of saving data
from your mobile app,
from Walkshare, just
by sending it
straight to an API.
You'll say, store this
data for this user,
and that user anywhere can go
back and retrieve that data.
And we're done.
So thank you.